what can you do to eliminate your double
chin besides surgery when eating carrots
do anything to my jawline
what do you Bugs Bunny bra like you mean
like to make your muscles stronger in
your neck there was a funny commercial
christiana or Thalgo if I'm not mistaken
did wear
please don't buy the chin exercise or
whatever at school you can't spot reduce
wear you have a problem area you can
lose overall body fat which can help
possibly your double chin surgery is an
option fillers are an option so great
one two three why does your heart race
and your hands get clammy when you see
someone you have a crush on this happens
to me a lot that's called arousal
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa that's a normal
sympathetic nervous system in action
your body's getting you prepared it's
getting excited it's being turned on
those are good things that means you're
feeling some kind of passion for that
person you should enjoy that feeling and
really live in the moment what is your
opinion on birth control making women
gain weight I've never had this problem
but I hear so many complaints about it
Maddi it does happen occasionally what
happens the majority of the time
actually is women initially put on
weight from starting birth control but
it's usually water weight that if you
stay on the birth control long enough it
equalizes and you actually end up losing
the water weight that you initially
gained my recommendation to my patients
is to stay with it to try it if it
doesn't work the way that they want we
could always switch medications or try
another form of birth control
I am HS 37 hi dr. Mike just want to know
is it bad to cross your legs often been
trying to find this out but to no avail
thank you I see what you're saying
because you're compressing your blood
vessels your veins and your arteries
when you cross your legs sometimes your
legs get pins and needles they go numb
as a result so yeah I generally would
say don't cross your legs but at the
same time it's not that big of a deal if
you listen to your body and you start
feeling any kind of discomfort change
your position it's really that simple
katia boo Fonda hey dr. Mike I have been
a licensed massage therapist for going
on five years now and I find that some
doctors can still be hesitant to
recommend massage or believe the
benefits of Massage Therapy what are
your thoughts on massage actually true
story me and my man Dan Owens here who's
sitting behind the camera are gonna get
a massage after this specifically a Thai
massage I personally believe in the
benefits of massage I also see the
scientific benefits of massage what
feels good to your muscles blood flow
how can you stimulate blood flow
naturally well you could break up
restrictions you can rub the muscle
which will bring more blood flow to that
area some warmth
healing factors dynamic flutter dear dr.
Mike I think my crush has crush on you
what should I do you should become a
poet because that was a really good line
right there actually dynamic butter what
you should do is you should tell your
crush that I'm answering your question
right now and maybe they'll give you
some kind of cred and you can then like
vibe I don't know what your kids call it
these days
biggest question how to stop being a
lazy ass my answer here is gonna
surprise you
most people think willpower comes prior
to action they think that they're just
gonna wake up motivated one day and then
they're gonna take action no it happens
the other way and it's a little bit
surprising you have to perform some sort
of action and as a result of whatever
action you perform you're gonna get some
benefit feel-good chemicals mastery of a
subject improvement admiration of others
fun and as a result of that you're gonna
get motivation and willpower which then
you could use to do other tasks kargh
ace 100 why are almost all medical terms
so long and hard to pronounce like
deoxyribonucleic acid that's just DNA I
think it's because a lot of medical
terms are derived from Latin Latin is a
complicated language and you can combine
terms by putting just a simple o in
between them I also think and this is my
conspiracy theory here all right turn on
the Shane Dawson music do you it's
because doctors don't want you to
understand what they're saying because
then they'll then they're not as special
I think lawyers do this I think all
specialties do this just use the regular
terms if it's front say front if it's
back say back doctors what are you doing
Cody
Mehmet qatal I hope I said that right
the real question how much doctor Mike
is too much only after you've watched
all of my hundred-plus videos three
times over and then watch them one more
time for good luck that might be too
much Rebekah V question why is it that
some people sneeze louder than others is
it dangerous to sneeze quietly I would
not curtail your sneeze
because when you curtail your sneezes
you're raising the pressure inside your
head the intracranial pressure
unnecessarily just enjoy the feeling of
a sneeze but sneeze correctly don't
seize into your hand don't just sneeze
into the world sneeze into your elbow so
that the bacteria can stay in your elbow
and you won't spread it to the rest of
the world by touching things what's the
deal with stage fright because I go on
stages very often these days and it
really bugs me before and while being on
stage Angelina you're not alone the
biggest fear in the world is not Heights
it's not spiders it's the fear of public
speaking or some other form of social
anxiety I've suffered from this my
friends have suffered from this the more
times you're able to expose yourself to
that kind of situation the better you're
gonna perform in the better you're gonna
do the second thing about that is if
you're able to look inside yourself and
wonder why is it that I'm so nervous
about going on stage and you can
confront those fears for example if you
say to yourself well if I stutter people
are gonna think I'm stupid pause right
there is that thought rational that if
you stutter once someone's gonna think
you're totally stupid possible not
likely and if they do they're the ones
that are making the incorrect conclusion
think about what's making you nervous to
go onstage attack those thoughts write
them down if it will help you put the
more rational thought in its place and
then go out and keep doing it it's never
gonna totally go away well that's a good
thing because that's your mind getting
you ready to go on stage and think
quickly to answer people's questions and
perform your very best Viki Pierce EPs
does anyone else think dr. Mike
seriously looks like many the makeup
artists sexy straight brother well thank
you for the sexy compliment yeah we've
been told this before in fact that's how
manny and i started talking on twitter
because someone tagged us and said that
we look really similar we actually get
along well and we chat via twitter all
the time we're supposed to get a collab
going sometime soon
but because we're on opposite coasts of
the United States it's not that easy but
I think it may be in the works
Cortese whoa what is a book you read
recently that you enjoyed
I really enjoyed Jonathan Heights
coddling of the American mind actually I
enjoyed it so much I'm going to be
reading one of his other books the
righteous mind
I think it's called a lot of his
thoughts that he put very eloquently in
his book I thought for a long time in my
practice with my patients the things
that I've observed in in college when I
was there and the things that are
happening on social media so I think
that if you're interested in that kind
of reading material definitely worth
checking it out
[Music]